I am in a terminal. I am going to fire up
python and I am going to show you how to use python
to do hashing for you because we are going to be doing
a lot of this in this class. One thing we can use
is hashlib. Hashlib has a couple of hashes available to you.
You have md5, sha1, 256. Those are the ones that we just
talked about so let's go ahead and get the md5 of something.
The way we do that is we say. X equals hashlib.md5 and
we say.
Now X is this hash object and the way we get something useful out of this is we
call the hex digest function on them. If we call hex digest on the result of
md5. We get this string. And this is the md5. Has of the string Fu.
And if I were to change, let's do this all in one line. Let's say
hashlib.md5, hello, hello. Whoops, hello, hello,
and call Hex Digest on it. We can see our
hash. Now, if I were to just change one of
these characters, let's say it changed to a capital O
We can see our hash completely changes. See we had
f five two blah blah blah two six three here.
So that's a neat property of this particular hashing function
and if we were to change this back to hello
hello we get our original hash. What's nice about a hash
algorithm like M d five its available on every system and if I type if I you
know hash hello hello On any system with MD5,
we're going to get the same result. That’s pretty cool.